Esta es una imagen extremadamente rara
un japonés con una pistola en la mano
los cazadores Son los únicos junto con
los policías y los tiradores deportivos
que pueden poseer un arma de fuego en el
país pero conseguirla es una carrera de
obstáculos entre seis meses y un año de
espera una autorización policial una
prueba escrita pruebas de alcohol y
drogas e incluso una investigación
vecinal
la policía informa a mis vecinos que
quiero un arma y les pregunta si soy
peligroso si he tenido algún problema
con ellos pueden preguntarle a mi mujer
tu marido quiere tener un arma te
preocupa si responde afirmativamente se
me niega la tenencia de un arma
los propietarios también hacen revisar
sus rifles todos los años una serie de
controles que disuade
al principio estamos motivados para
conseguir la licencia de rifle Pero como
este Dios o al cabo de un tiempo resulta
desmotivador Así que los jóvenes que
quieren ser cazadores le resulta difícil
seguir adelante y decirte
Japón está orgulloso de sus resultados
aunque no hay cifras precisas sobre la
posesión ilegal el país tiene menos de
un arma por cada 100 habitantes en
Francia 80 veces más en Estados Unidos
500 veces más el número de armas es
incluso superior al de ciudadanos
la cultura anti armas en Japón se
remonta al siglo 19 el nuevo emperador
meiji registra armas de fuego para
asegurar su poder tras la Segunda Guerra
Mundial Estados Unidos victorioso sobre
Japón remató confiscan armas para acabar
con el militarismo japonés 75 años
después el atractivo de las armas no
puede ser más bajo es normal pasar por
todos estos controles desde que se creó
el reglamento de armas ha habido casos
de terrorismo en el extranjero o
tiroteos esto ha hecho que la ley sea
mucho más estricta el enemigo actual es
la mafia japonesa los yakuzas Son los
únicos que venden armas ilegalmente sin
licencia este antiguo policía luchó
contra este tráfico
incluso los ciudadanos que no son
mafiosos pasan a veces por la yakuza
para conseguir un arma sabemos que
Existen algunas redes de importación
ilegal desde filipinas Corea del Norte o
incluso Rusia
hoy en día también se puede encontrar
armas personalizadas o piezas arregladas
en una impresora con las que se puede
matar gente
Así que no resulta difícil controlar a
este nivel
se trata de una réplica del arma
responsable de la muerte de shinzo ave
en julio de 2022 mientras pronunciaba un
discurso el ex Primer Ministro de Japón
es asesinado el caso salta los titulares
y el arma homicida llama la atención
porque en este país donde los disparos
son poco frecuentes fue un rifle de
fabricación casera el que disparó las
balas
el asesino declaró que había reutilizado
proyectiles
la llenaba de polvora negra
añadía las bolas de metal y las
introducía antes de dispararla
según este experto ahora cualquiera
puede fabricar un arma a partir de
información en internet por un precio
muy bajo
para fabricar este rifle se necesitan
unos 150 euros como no se puede hacer la
prueba en una casa Hay que ir a la
montaña donde no hay nadie a principios
de marzo la policía introdujo un sistema
de filtros en línea para las búsquedas
sobre fabricación de armas de fuego el
asesinato de shinzo ave ha traumatizado
aparte del país y fortaleció aún más el
sentimiento anti armas que ya prevalece
en Japón
estoy en contra del porte de armas para
civiles Fíjate en Estados Unidos por
culpa de esto hay muchos casos de
tiroteos en las escuelas
estoy agradecida por el sistema japonés
y me alegro de haber nacido aquí
no sé necesariamente sobre leyes de
protección de armas
soy vieja y he podido vivir toda mi vida
aquí sin preocuparme por ellas
los asesinatos por arma de fuego siguen
siendo raros solo un caso en 2021 para
un país de 125 millones de habitantes
los asesinatos suelen ser con arma
blanca sin embargo también en este caso
el control está muy presente Aunque
algunas armas corto punzantes tengan
excepciones
si lleva una navaja pequeña en el coche
o en el bolsillo y le interrogan puede
ser detenido pero una katana es
diferente
puede llevarlo un centro comercial o a
una estación por ejemplo bueno no
debemos hacer eso
hay que portarla bien y tener una razón
válida para llevar una katana el arma de
los samuráis incluso este símbolo de
Japón no escapa de la vigilancia total
cada espada debe registrarse Pero esta
vez como bien cultural un estatuto muy
especial creado por el archipiélago para
proteger su patrimonio
tras la Segunda Guerra Mundial el
ejército estadounidense confiscó
nuestras katanas muchas de las cuales
crearon esparcidas por todo el mundo los
ancianos japoneses trabajaron duro para
conseguir el estatus de bien cultural
esto hizo posible la repatriación de
nuestras espadas
en 2021 Japón registró más de 9.000
nuevas katanas en su territorio frente a
sólo 580 armas de fuego alentado por los
ocupantes estadounidenses apom tomó el
camino de un país sin pistolas ni rifles
una paradoja cuando hoy en día los
tiroteos mortales se disparan en Estados
Unidos Se confirma la política del
archipiélago no es probable que cambien
aquí las normas sobre el porte de armas